hello and welcome to swipe coming up
technology and the elderly is the
industry missing out on an untapped
market 30 years since the first one we
put the new Apple Mac grow through its
paces forget google glass meet the smart
contact lens and i challenge you to a
duel we run through the latest gaming
releases new phones games and gadgets
are almost always aimed at the younger
generation they're the ones most
interested in there for the people who
buy the products well that's the theory
but the UK population is aging and many
older people use devices like tablets
and smartphones every day so should
technology firms be thinking more about
senior citizens it's easy to assume that
older people aren't that interested in
using the latest technology but the
reality for many is very different 67
year old Margaret Goodwin loves gadgets
she owns a tablet a laptop and a
smartphone and she's passionate about
helping others improve their tech skills
I would say just try it because it is
daunting it is when you haven't worked
with computers in your working life
perhaps it is quite daunting to engage
with a technology that you haven't ever
had to but it's worth the effort it's
worth just giving it a try it's actually
very very easy but it's not like this
for everyone research carried out by age
UK shows that 14 million people are
digitally excluded that means they've
never had access to a computer or a
smartphone and they can't justify buying
expensive hardware or taking the time to
learn new skills so should tech
companies be thinking about the elderly
a bit more when they create new products
there is no company that I can think of
that is actively going out of its way to
engage and educate an older audience as
to why this would be of you see them why
they should use say online shopping or
user tablet to get a newspaper nobody's
actively doing that they're sort of
expected to somehow pick up on the
messages that are actually not aimed for
them and already on their radar
I can t really great consoles like the
we showed that gaming isn't reserved for
the younger generation and scientists in
San Francisco claim to have found a way
to reverse cognitive decline by using a
brain training game so a developer's
missing out on a huge untapped market
there's eighty percent more wealth
typically amongst 55 to 64 year olds in
the UK than there is amongst 25 to 34
year olds now sure some of that is
wrapped up in things like pensions and
housing but the fact is there is that
wealth pot there for brands and
companies to tap into in the 21st
century we all know technology shapes
our lives whatever our age but what can
be enabling for some also risks
excluding others Gemma Morris Sky News
you're watching swype coming up we take
a glimpse into Google's future but first
as the Mac celebrates its 30th birthday
here it's white we've had a chance to go
hands-on with the latest desktop machine
the new Mac Pro couldn't be more unlike
its predecessor or any of the macs to
date but don't be fooled by its
diminutive stature this machine is fast
martin stanford put it to the test
thanks Gemma and happy birthday apple
with a look at the new Mac Pro and here
it is it's quite a little beasty barely
a foot tall 25 centimeters does way a
bit 5 kilograms or thereabouts-- but
there's an awful lot of computing power
to get inside this very small form
factor let me talk you through the
connection panel at the back here you've
got four USB 3 s6 Thunderbolts to
Ethernet an HDMI for projector or
television and your power button and
power connection inside there's not an
awful lot that users can change but
there's a limited amount of options
there are two memory boards with eight
gigs of memory in each here and two more
this side so 32 gigs on this particular
model and in terms of the circuit boards
this is the one that contains the flash
memory that's working on the PCI Express
connection which Apple say make it super
super fast so I thought we needed to put
the new map
a real-life test so we'll hook it up to
a bit of kit here and one of the things
we have to do here at Sky and a lot of
video production companies have to do
the same is to compress high quality
video you filmed and edited ready for
displaying on a website so we're going
to put that to the test through the
brand new Mac Pro and compare it to our
standard edit suite which I've got here
as well an old Mac tower and it's
feeding final cut seven through this
screen here so here's the piece of music
the organ clip on my timeline I'm going
to go in and ask to export that using
QuickTime conversion let's put a
stopwatch on this so I'm going to start
that and save away over on my other
screen here which is being powered by
the brand new I've got my clip here it
is in final cut 10.1 I am going to ask
it to share I'm going to time this share
let's set the old timer going here and
there's the share successful so it's all
done in 12 minutes and 46 seconds over
on the old Mac it's 20 minutes or more
before the same job is done all of which
doesn't prove very much to be honest
it's not exactly a like-for-like
comparison but with the right
specification this little tower say
Apple will actually drive three 4k
displays and can edit eight streams of
4k video simultaneously without dropping
a single pixel might cost you a bit
though you're watching swype coming up
we update you on the week's technology
headlines but first Google already has
driverless cars computerized glasses and
Wi-Fi balloons but now it has a contact
lens that monitors glucose levels skies
Chloe kolpin reports now on the latest
development from Google's xlab this
little contact lens could change
millions of lives it's able to monitor
glucose levels in tears a potential
reprieve for millions of diabetics who
constantly have to watch their blood
sugar levels the lens made by google
looks and feels like a standard soft
lens but it's fitted with a microchip
and a wireless transmitter
which sends crucial data to the user the
technology giant says it took more than
a year of soul during hair thin wires to
miniaturize the electronics essentially
building the tiny chips from scratch
we've had to work really hard to develop
tiny low power electronics that operate
on very low levels of energy and really
small glucose sensors google assure us
that the electronics in the lens don't
obscure vision because they lie outside
the pupil and the iris the product was
developed over the past 18 months in the
clandestine Google X lab that also came
up with a driverless car and web surfing
I glasses nearly 400 million people
around the world suffer with diabetes
with many having to do an invasive
fingerprint test to draw blood and check
their glucose levels and they might have
to carry on doing it for a bit longer
because this prototype isn't likely to
reach consumers for five years however
it's just one of several medical devices
being designed by companies to make
glucose monitoring for diabetics more
convenient and less invasive really
early on we're confident about how the
technology is going so far but there's a
huge amount of work left to do and so
we're actively looking for partners to
help us out with the next phases of the
project Google haven't revealed how many
people are working on the project or how
much they've invested in it but if
accurate medics say it could be a
game-changer Chloe Copeland Sky News
you're watching swype coming up prepare
to board your longboats and join us on
our games review but first here's a
roundup of anything you might have
missed over the past few days former
footballer Stan Collymore has deleted
his Twitter account after accusing the
site of not doing enough to combat
abusive tweets collymore now a radio
presenter was sent death threats and was
racially abused after suggesting
Liverpool striker Luis Suarez dived in a
match against Aston Villa twitter says
it can't stop people from saying
offensive hurtful things but the company
insists it does take action on a legal
content I've no problem with weave with
honesty
opinions if people think I'm an idiot
and they're more than welcome to say
they're also more than welcome within
the laws of the United Kingdom to bring
up my past factually whether that be
good bad or indifferent I have no issue
in no problem with that whatsoever that
is genuine use of freedom of speech but
freedom of speech means that if anybody
walks past me here now and calls me some
of the things or makes the threats that
they did they would be arrested and they
would be processed interested in
facebook has peaked and the social
network could lose up to eighty percent
of its users by 2017 that's according to
academics at Princeton University
they've predicted the demise using
theories on the spread of disease
combined with google searches for
facebook comparing the site to a disease
the researchers said eventually users
begin to leave and recovery spreads
infectiously as users begin to lose
interest struggling smartphone maker
blackberry has seen its share price
increased dramatically after the
Pentagon said it would order thousands
of new handsets last week the US said it
was buying more mobility devices like
smartphones and tablets including 80,000
BlackBerry's the Canadian company's
shares have gone up by more than sixty
percent since last month when it
reported a quarterly loss of more than
2.6 billion pounds it's not quite game
over but things aren't looking great for
Nintendo after more disappointing wii u
sales over 600 million pounds was wiped
off the firm's value on monday as
console sales fell sixty-eight percent
the creator of super mario says it
expects to lose 145 million pounds in
the year to march and the world's worst
password has been revealed 123456 was
hacked more times than any other
combination in 2013 beating the previous
champion password which was simply the
word password other common ones were ABC
123 admin I love you and Photoshop
splash data who produced the report
recommends longer passwords with at
least eight mixed characters now it's
that time again where we recruit the
finest minds from the world of gaming to
review the latest releases this week's
joystick hero is cameron robinson
so Ned hog is kind of weird to look at
it first imagine a cross between
tug-of-war and fencing except in this 2d
plane you have to try and get to the
other side of the screen and your
opponent is trying to do the same when
you first look at it you might think it
looks very simple very basic it's very
fast very twitchy and actually becomes
quite heavily skill-based once you get
the handle of the of the quick controls
so you can like stab with your sword you
can throw your sword and do all these
things it's very very quick and if you
eventually managed to fight past your
opponent and kill them they then respond
and you got to fight past them again
that's where the tug-of-war element
comes in if you eventually get to the
end zone you get to celebrate and then
you get eaten by this weird giant snake
thing whereas when these games that you
can play with someone in there very
quickly gets our he teed lots of
shouting and then a great sense of
victory when you finally crush them rust
is looking like it might be the next big
thing in terms of PC gaming the premises
you're in this post-apocalyptic zombie
survival world we've heard all before
right pretty dull but the twist is that
it's got lots of elements of the game
minecraft in it or very similar so you
can craft and build shelters to survive
from the zombies room around the line
then the and the wildlife it's very
difficult I think that's why people are
getting quite attracted to you start
playing you're gonna die a lot so you
might die from hunger you might die from
zombies you might die from other players
you might die from eating meat from the
animals you kill that you didn't cook
properly all these type of things but if
you eventually get handle of it and
survived because that's what the games
all about comes really really fun last
night I had a dream so the banner saga
is eye candy it's a beautiful game it
imagined kind of almost studio ghibli
esque and like beautiful hand-drawn
animation except with a Nordic kind of
Scandinavian vibe and it's a
role-playing game set in this kind of
fictional Scandinavia you control these
kind of caravans of of travelers moving
from from one place to another because
there's basically this this ancient evil
has awakened why are we alive when even
the gods
it's a really interesting story and it's
absolutely gorgeous to just look at so
the game works by you travel from place
to place you make decisions and you get
in these kind of turn-based combat
situations it's something quite
different and if you're looking for
something which is very story driven to
get the rest of January this is a great
pick so if like me you're quite excited
about the rosetta spacecraft landing on
this comet and everything in the future
well I've got the game for you it's
called kerbal space program in this game
you can have your own space program
launch your own missions to hack a lot
of a fun and you basically it's not
humans or you're sending in space is
this kind of adorable little race of
people called kerbals but you have
complete control over the space program
so you start off by having to build your
rocket you've got loads of different
parts to choose from to assemble and
then you can launch into space you can
try and go to other planets it's very
difficult I think my first attempt my
rocket just blew up because I built it
wrong second detent went up and then
came back down yes so you're gonna have
to be prepared to kill a lot of
astronauts and maybe why I was never
actually worked at NASA but it's it's a
lot of fun and I can highly recommend if
you've got a bit of our a bit of a lot
of love of science inside you like I do
that's it for this week remember you can
catch up with the breaking tech stories
all week on Sky News for iPad our
smartphone apps as sky news com see you
next time bye bye